Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Elise LECAMP
Oh putain de bordel de merde.
Oh fait chier, oh merde,
oh bordel.
C'est pas beau hein, tous ces gros mots
dans la bouche d'une femme.
C'est ce que tous les parents
répètent aux petites filles.
« Ça ne se fait pas pour une fille.
C'est pas beau. »
Peut-être.
Mais moi, je pense au contraire
que tous ces gros mots,
que ces « mots d'hommes »,
dans la bouche des femmes
sont indispensables.
Tout comme Madeleine Pelletier,
première femme française psychiatre
en 1905,
je crois, et je la cite, que :
« la suppression de la servitude féminine
passe par la suppression
de la coquetterie, de la retenue,
de la pudeur exagérée,
des mièvreries de l'esprit
et du langage. »
J'aimerais ne plus jamais entendre :
« une fille ne fait pas ça ! »
Il faut s'asseoir correctement,
mais cela n'a rien à voir
avec le fait d'être une fille.
C'est juste plus poli.
Il faut éviter d'élever la voix,
mais pas parce qu'on est une fille,
juste parce qu'on ne se fait pas
entendre en criant.
J'aimerais ne plus jamais entendre
un père annoncer à la cantonade
que le premier homme qui s'approchera
de sa fille sera décapité
alors qu'il rit gaiement aux ravages
probables de son fils
sur la gente féminine.
J'aimerais encore moins entendre
une mère qui,
pour calmer les cris de son fils,
va tranquillement lui asséner :
« Mais enfin, tu vas pas pleurer
comme une fille ? »
Et pourquoi pas ?
Il faut arrêter
d'essentialiser les petites filles.
Il faut cesser
de les limiter aux stéréotypes de genre.
Et pourquoi on ferait ça ?
Peut-être pour leur donner
la possibilité du choix,
voire du choix de l'émancipation,
sans passer par la case obligée
des qualités dites « féminines »,
comme la tendresse, la douceur,
l'attention à autrui, la séduction
ou même la maternité.
Et puis, un garçon manqué...
c'est souvent une fille réussie.
Je suis née à Téhéran
avec la révolution islamique.
Ma grande chance fut d'avoir grandi
dans une famille athée.
Après la révolution khomeyniste,
le voile est devenu obligatoire
pour toutes les femmes,
mais aussi pour toutes
les petites filles.
Je me souviens,
quand on m'a recouverte de noir,
le premier jour d'école,
j'avais six ans,
j'voulais pas porter le voile.
J'ai crié, j'ai pleuré,
j'ai piétiné mon voile.
Sans succès.
Et finalement,
la seule réponse qui s'est imposée
à l'enfant que j'étais
fut de montrer mon cul.
Si si, tous les jours,
après la sonnerie,
je retirais le voile
et la tenue réglementaire
qui allait avec
pour me précipiter dans la cour
cul-nu,
poursuivie par les femmes-corbeaux
qui trébuchaient
sur les pans de leur tchador.
A six ans, c'est un spectacle
super réjouissant.
J'ai aussi monté une troupe de danse
clandestine dans les toilettes de l'école,
pour reproduire les chorégraphies
de West Side Story
dont la VHS circulait
au marché noir,
et quand nous nous sommes fait surprendre
(on se fait toujours surprendre),
je me suis justifiée
en parlant d'un spectacle de cabaret,
ce qui a provoqué illico
la convocation de mes parents
à qui la directrice de l'école,
une horrible femme
qui ne souriait jamais,
a remis le numéro
d'un exorciste.
Mes parents ont beaucoup ri.
Moi aussi quand j'ai compris
ce qu'était un exorciste.
Des années ont passé
sur le voile de mon enfance.
Des années durant lesquelles
j'ai pu mettre du sens
sur ma réaction physique
et enfantine.
Le voile sexualise le corps
de la femme.
En l'occultant, le voile
fait le nid de la concupiscence.
En comparaison,
le cul-nu de mon enfance
était super innocent.
Il est absurde de croire
que le voile protège la femme.
Il la vulnérabilise
et crée une hiérarchie des femmes,
de la prude qui le porte
à la pute qui le refuse.
Et pourtant, les chiffres venus d’Égypte
sont confondants.
92% des femmes y sont voilées,
et 96% subissent
des attouchements sauvages
dans les rues.
La blague qui circule au Caire
dit que les 4% restantes
n'étaient pas chez elles
le jour du sondage.
Je ne veux pas être une victime.
Je ne veux pas être toujours en danger.
J'en ai marre d'être réduite
à mon corps intime et sexué.
Et c'est le cas depuis
très, très, très, très longtemps.
Hier, c'était le corset et le mariage
qui empêchaient
le corps féminin
de se mouvoir librement.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le voile,
et la sacralisation
pour le moins hystérique
de la virginité
qui le discrimine.
Face à cette oppression,
l'essentiel, à mon sens,
pour les femmes,
pour toutes les femmes,
c'est de posséder
pleinement leur corps
pour se réapproprier leurs droits.
C'est pour ne jamais l'oublier
que je me répète régulièrement
les paroles de Madame de Saint-Ange
dans « La Philosophie dans le Boudoir »
du Marquis de Sade.
« Ton corps est à toi
et à toi seule,
il n'y a que toi seule au monde
qui ait le droit d'en jouir,
et d'en faire jouir qui bon te semble. »
C'est beau, hein ?
C'est Sade.
Depuis les gynécées grecs,
ces appartements réservés aux femmes
à l'intérieur de la maison -
double protection pour le corps féminin -
toute l'histoire
de l'émancipation féminine
peut se lire à travers
le passage progressif du corps féminin
de l'espace privé
à l'espace public,
de l'invisibilité
à la visibilité.
Le travail, le vote,
la liberté sexuelle,
tout cela se joue
dans l'espace public.
Et pourtant, on continue d'élever
les petites filles
dans la crainte de l'extérieur.
On laisse les garçons
jouer dehors,
mais les filles, on les cantonne
à l'intérieur.
Seulement voilà,
d'après l'OMS,
un tiers des femmes
dans le monde
sont victimes de violences
physiques et sexuelles,
la très grande majorité,
de la part de leur compagnon.
A l'intérieur.
Un quart des Américaines
subissent des violences domestiques.
Toujours à l'intérieur.
En France, d'après les chiffres
du Haut Conseil à l’Égalité
entre Hommes et Femmes,
entre 2010 et 2012,
83 000 femmes
ont été victimes de viol
et de tentative de viol.
83% connaissaient leur agresseur.
Seules 11% osent porter plainte.
Si elles n'osent pas,
c'est qu'elles se sentent coupables.
Et si elles se sentent coupables,
c'est que leur éducation
et leur environnement
les renvoient
à cette culpabilité.
Le philosophe John Stuart Mill -
il en faut toujours un -
le constatait déjà
en 1851
quand il déclarait que
toutes les femmes
sont élevées dès l'enfance
dans la croyance que
l'idéal de leur caractère est
le contraire de celui d'un homme.
Elles sont dressées à
ne pas vouloir par elles-mêmes,
à ne pas se conduire
d'après leur volonté,
mais à se soumettre.
C'est contre cette soumission
que je me bats
et le système
pour lequel je me bats
est un système égalitaire.
Il n'est pas question
d'un système matriarcal
qui ne réglera aucun problème
mais reproduira les mêmes
mécanismes en miroir.
Et puis, une femme ne vaut
pas plus qu'un homme.
Elle vaut autant.
Alors, comment faire pour
instaurer l'égalité ?
Non parce que franchement,
en toute honnêteté,
c'est un peu la merde,
quand même.
Parce que si tout commence
à la maison,
tout se poursuit
à l'école.
Il faut rappeler ici
que deux tiers
des 775 millions d'analphabètes
dans le monde
sont des femmes.
Les autres, toutes celles
qui ont la chance d'aller à l'école
sont sujettes à ce que Claude Steele,
professeur à Stanford,
appelle « la menace du stéréotype »,
et qui fonctionne
comme une prophétie auto-réalisatrice.
En gros, parce que les femmes
se croient moins bonnes en maths,
elles finissent par le devenir.
En France, deux enseignants-chercheurs
en psychologie sociale,
Isabelle Regnier et Pascal Huguet,
ont demandé à 454 élèves
de sixième et de cinquième
de reproduire une figure qui mêle
des triangles et des carrés
de différentes couleurs.
Lorsque l'exercice était présenté
comme un exercice de dessin,
les filles réussissaient mieux
que les garçons.
Mais proposé comme un exercice
de géométrie,
les garçons surpassaient
systématiquement les filles.
C'est navrant, triste, désolant, tragique.
Tout aussi navrant, triste,
désolant et tragique
que les propos tenus par Larry Summers,
président d'Harvard,
qui déclarait en 2005 que
« l'absence des femmes
parmi les grands mathématiciens
était liée à des
phénomènes biologiques ».
C'est pas fini, il rajoutait :
« les femmes possédant moins
d'aptitudes intrinsèques
pour les mathématiques
que les hommes ».
Voilà, voilà.
Mais cette fois,
l'histoire se termine bien.
Parce que c'est justement
une femme, d'origine iranienne,
Maryam Mirzakhani,
justement diplômée d'Harvard,
qui lui fermera joyeusement
son clapet en 2014
en devenant la première femme à recevoir
la prestigieuse médaille Fields.
Voilà, c'est comme ça que
nous avancerons vers l'égalité,
en faisant la preuve,
par notre compétence,
notre volonté et notre ambition.
Mais pour y parvenir,
il faut renverser la table.
Et pour renverser la table,
il faut regarder le monde autrement.
A Téhéran, j'avais demandé
à mon professeur de religion,
qui ne nous regardait jamais,
« nous, les filles »,
pourquoi je devais
porter le voile.
Il avait répondu
par un lapidaire :
« Parce que vous êtes, vous les femmes,
des objets dangereux. »
C'était méprisant, c'est sûr.
Mais c'était salvateur :
j'ai 8 ans, et j'fais si peur que ça ?
Avec mes cheveux, mes poignets,
mes chevilles de rien du tout,
j'fais peur à un type
tellement plus vieux ?
Mais alors, j'ai des super-pouvoirs ?
Toutes les femmes
ont des super-pouvoirs ?
Ce jour-là, j'ai décidé
de garder mon super-pouvoir,
pour ne plus jamais
être réduite à un objet.
Voila comment
j'ai commencé
par regarder
le monde autrement,
en devenant sujet.
Et en tant que sujet,
pour s'accomplir en tant que sujet,
nous avons besoin
de notre mémoire et de notre histoire.
A mon arrivée à Paris,
je m'attendais à avoir atterri
dans le pays de Simone de Beauvoir.
Je m'attendais
à les croiser partout,
les Simones de Beauvoir que
mon père m'avait promises,
dans la vie, et dans les livres.
Eh bien, elles n'étaient pas là.
Elles étaient occultées,
voilées.
Aujourd'hui,
Olympe de Gouges
et sa Déclaration des Droits
de la Femme et de la Citoyenne
sont entrées dans
les manuels scolaires.
Mais elles sont où,
toutes les autres ?
Toutes celles qui peuvent
être des références
et nous offrir la possibilité
du choix, du fameux choix.
Elle est où, Hubertine Auclert,
première femme française
à se dire « féministe »
et qui lança une grève de l'impôt
avec ce slogan génial :
« Je ne vote pas,
je ne paye pas. »
Elle est où,
Jane Dieulafoy,
qui traversa la Perse
en 1881-1882
et apporta sa contribution
fondamentale à l'étude
de la Perse Antique et l'origine
de l'architecture occidentale ?
Il suffit de se promener au Louvre
pour remarquer
qu'une salle porte son nom,
et c'est travestie en homme
que cette insoumise
a reçu la Légion d'Honneur,
à une époque où le travestissement
était interdit.
Elle est où, Marguerite Durand,
féministe, syndicaliste,
rédactrice et journaliste,
qui lança avec succès
le premier quotidien féminin
La Fronde,
non seulement entièrement
écrit mais aussi fabriqué
et distribué par les femmes,
et dans les pages duquel
il était davantage question
de politique internationale
et d'économie
que de cuisine et de mode ?
Elles sont où, toutes ces femmes
incroyables qui nous ont précédées
et qui peuvent exciter en nous
le désir d'aller plus loin
que ce foutu plafond de verre
contre lequel nous nous brisons
génération après génération ?
Aujourd'hui, autant qu'hier,
l'obscurantisme s'en prend aux femmes
à leur corps, à leurs droits.
Et aujourd'hui, tout autant qu'hier,
nous avons besoin
des Lumières pour nous battre.
Pas pour nous défendre,
pour nous battre.
Les Lumières, c'est piétiner son héritage
quand il n'est que la somme
de nos préjugés.
Les Lumières,
c'est raisonner
en hommes et femmes
libres et autonomes,
capables d'exercer
notre esprit critique
pour détruire la prison
de notre naissance,
de notre sexe,
de notre condition sociale.
Les Lumières, c'est un appel
à l'insoumission.
L'insoumission,
ça commence
par des gros mots
dans la bouche des femmes,
et des professeurs qui poussent
les filles à aller plus loin
en mathématiques.
Ce sont des pères
qui ne craignent pas
la liberté sexuelle
de leurs filles
et des mères qui se battent
pour les envoyer à l'école
et les y maintenir.
L'insoumission, c'est le premier
pas vers notre révolution.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)